[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es ein richtig tolles
rezept und zwar habe ich zum schnecken
kekse gebacken cinnamon rollkies richtig
cool oder also zimtschnecken
sie sind schnecken allgemein finde ich
ja schon richtig lecker com probieren am
anfang bin ich ja schon richtig lecker
allgemein aus hefeteig und da dachte ich
komme für die weihnachtsbäckerei müssen
es auch plätzchen seien diese nämlich
länger haltbar und man kann einfach
jeden tag davon naschen
ich glaube sie schmecken gut und komme
einen darf probieren und ich zeige euch
jetzt wie man den teig zubereitet ich
nehme dafür nehme ich den ganz normalen
123 123 löwe teig das heißt ein teil
zucker zweiteiler butter drei teile mail
das ist super einfach und braucht auch
nur ganz ganz wenige zutaten für den
mürbeteig brauche ich 50 gramm
puderzucker 100 gramm kalte butter 150
gramm mehl eine prise salz etwas vanille
extrakt und für die füllung nämlich ein
eiweiß habe ich 30 gramm braunem zucker
einen teelöffel zimt und 40 gramm
gehackte mandeln zuerst bereite ich
jetzt den mut so dafür nehme ich jetzt
einfach den puderzucker es geht super
einfach deswegen mache ich das hier auf
der arbeitsplatte dann die kalte butter
und jetzt kann ich das gab es ja schon
mal so ein bisschen zerhacken dadurch
dass der teig dämme beträgt gehackt
wurde früher einfach mit einem messer
ist er auch eine zeit lang aktg
also kann man auch fangen backteig
[Musik]
sie können auch gerne die finger nehmen
aber beim ipc ist ganz wichtig dass er
nicht warum wird das heißt man muss ihn
einfach ganz schnell verkneten
dann kommt jetzt hier das mehl dazu
etwas salz und jetzt muss mir jemand
dass vanille extrakt öffnen den un hände
sind schmutzig
nur einfach so einen guten schuss
vanille extrakt noch rein perfekt
und jetzt den teig ganz rasch zu einem
geschmeidigen teig verkneten
[Musik]
den teig drücke ich jetzt ein bisschen
flach legen in einer schüssel decken ab
und stellt ihn für mindestens 30 minuten
kühl und gleichzeitig euch noch wie wir
die füllung verrühren
für die füllung kann ich jetzt hier die
zutaten einfach verrühren
ich nehme hier weiß dann den braunen
zucker weil sie jetzt kein braun und
zucker habt können natürlich auch in
weißem zucker nimmt ihr müsst auch nicht
den kompletten zucker leben also wenn
ihr das gerne etwas weniger süß mögt
nehmt einfach ein bisschen weniger dann
alles gut verrühren und am ende noch die
mandeln betreiben die sorgen hand über
ihn richtig tollen kampf die füllung
werde ich jetzt gleich abdecken und
einfach stehen lassen bis der teig so
weit ist
[Musik]
wenn die füllung soll ich hier etwas
flüssig ist also bei mir war das
wahrscheinlich ein sehr großes eiweiß
dann könnt ihr noch ein paar gemahlene
mandeln mit dazu geben die finden die
flüssigkeit ein bisschen jetzt kann ich
das ganze abdecken also ich gehe noch
ein bisschen gemahlene mandeln mit
reinen text dann ab und lass es so lange
stehen bis der teig geben auch so weit
ist der teig ist jetzt gut durch gekühlt
und ich habe ihn jetzt nach dem
kühlschrank einfach nur mal kurz
durchgeknetet so ist er geschmeidig
jetzt nehme ich nur ein ganz bisschen
hier und jetzt soll ich den teig etwa
einen millimeter dünn aus
[Musik]
wenn ihr das ganze auf einer silikon
mathe oder zum beispiel auf einer bank
folie oder backpapier aus holz habt ihr
auch den vorteil dass ihr die seiten so
einschlagen können sodass ein schönes
rechteck entsteht
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier den zimt masse drauf
streichen
[Musik]
meine platte halbiere ich jetzt in der
mitte damit ich schöne kleine kekse
erhalte und da müsste einfach drauf
aufpassen falls silikon mathe oder eine
dauerwelle benutzt dass ihr keine
spitzen gegenstände verwendet also kein
messer zum schneiden und jetzt könnt ihr
das ganze auf rollen und bevor ich jetzt
scheiben runter schneide ich das ganze
jetzt ein
das heißt ich packe jetzt diese rollen
in frischhaltefolie ein friseur ein
damit ich gleich schöne schein runter
schneiden kann und wenn ihr sie jetzt
darunter schneidet dann kann es einfach
sein dass diese spirale nicht mal so
schön sichtbar ist
die gefrorenen zimt rollen die können
dann in 0,5 zentimeter breite scheiben
geschnitten werden und dann lege ich sie
auf ein backblech und jetzt kommen sie
in den vorgeheizten backofen bei 190
grad ober unterhitze und da brauchen sie
dann etwa sieben bis zehn minuten
die kekse sind jetzt gebacken und auch
abgekühlt und sie sehen so schon
wirklich super aus aber ich finde
zimtschnecken sind sie erst dann wenn
sie auch eine klasse haben jetzt könnt
ihr entweder wie bei normalen
zimtschnecken einer klausur mit
frischkäse puderzucker und zitrone
machen oder ihr macht es so wie ich ich
mache es nur einer aus puderzucker und
zitrone
weil sie ein paar länger haltbarer ist
als frischkäse habe ich hier 100 gramm
puderzucker geben ein bisschen
zitronensaft noch rein
und wer möchte kann auch noch ein
bisschen vanille extrakt erkämpfen
[Musik]
die klausur will ich jetzt in einem
gefrierbeutel ihr könnt sie aber auch
gerne mit dem löffel einfach drüber
laufen lassen
aber so kann ich das ein bisschen besser
portionieren
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier eine ganz kleine
spitze wegschneiden und dann die klausur
über die zimtschnecken drüber laufen
lassen und die muss dann natürlich fest
werden und danach können wir sie gleich
probieren
also eigentlich hast du schon probiert
jetzt nochmal problem ja bitte bitte ich
habe jetzt auch schon probiert
ich finde so voll lecker ich bin ja ja
und ihr müsst jetzt einfach am besten in
so einer blechdose aufbewahrt keksdose
oder sind die wirklich also mehrere
wochen haltbar und weisen auf
wahrscheinlich aber nicht weil sie
schlecht werden sondern weil sie leer
sind ja voll lecker geht er ich hab da
mache ich noch mal eine größere portion
und da können wir wirklich er ganz viele
vorbereiten und ihr könnt ja auch diese
rollen einfach eingefroren lassen und
auch nach bedarf immer mal wieder
frische aufbacken das war auch ein
cooles ein früherer rezept falls ihr die
falls er die cookies nach machen möchtet
dann schaut auch cds - blog.de vorbei da
steht noch mal alles ganz genau und ich
wünsche euch viel spaß und nach backen
und bis zum nächsten mal
und jetzt freuen welche für die vorteile
und wenn ihr noch andere rezepte sucht
könnt ihr auch mal in meine playlist
vorbeischauen denn ich habe auch die
letzten jahre immer ganz ganz tolles
weihnachtsgebäck gezaubert aber kein
zaun nein ich muss erst fotos machen und
einen pfleger
er kann den dackel augen schon ein
[Musik]